well you got married since i got married
yeah congratulations
thank you i was actually on your show
like right before we got married and i i
was like kelly i'm getting married in a
couple weeks i love the color
look at that yeah we did a last-minute
wedding where
we weren't really we didn't think we
were gonna be able to get married this
past year and with the pandemic because
we were gonna
have like a real thing and and then
in like september october we were just
like let's just
let's just get married like why are we
waiting yeah and so save your money and
buy something cool like a house
rather than a wedding yeah so we planned
in like three weeks
we had five friends get tested and we
kind of did an outdoor thing as you see
on the beach and we we ended up zooming
our families but i didn't think about
that in advance because
you just don't think about you know
zooms and
weddings and so like 10 minutes before
the ceremony i'm like
oh like we should probably zoom our
families
and so i'm like frantically trying to
get a zoom link going
and like i don't know how the internet
was down and
so you know we're like sending it out
we're like we hope we remembered to send
like
send it to everybody we forgot a few
people i think that you know
the it's a good pass the whole global
pandemic thing yeah it's a good it's a
good like
hey we tried we tried effort yeah and i
i for sure saved a lot of money because
my family dude we're southern we like to
eat
yeah that would have bankrupted yeah
food and drinks
if your son and it's the food and drinks
yeah my mom didn't like any of the fancy
food she's about you got any sliders
flyer fried chicken i don't want this
ahi tuna yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help